Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier? Man hört's grumeln, glaube ich.
Wir sind in der Filmwerkstatt in Düsseldorf. Und wir sitzen hier, unterhalten uns ganz leise, denn wir sitzen bereits auf der Bühne und vor uns sitzt das Publikum. Und in zehn Minuten geht es los. Wir sprechen hier auf Einladung über KI. Was hast du mitgebracht?
Wir feuern heute Clips ab von Markus Gabriels und Christian Ohle. Beide im Kontrast. Wir haben ja hier auch das Subthema Latenz. Und beide reden über KI und Gefühle. Und Gefühle sind ja laut Peter Fuchs das Unaussprechbare, das man dann gerade noch mit Gefühlslabels markiert, um zu sagen, übrigens hier gibt es unaussprechbares Gefühle. Damit holt man sich auch ein bisschen Reflektionssperre rein. Man muss dann gar nicht so viel erklären. Man sagt einfach, ich habe Gefühle und alle so, ich nehme deine Angst, deine Wut, deine Liebe ganz ernst. Das kontrastieren wir heute. Denn der eine unterwirft sich Gott und gibt die Menschheit verloren. Und der andere sagt, wir können jetzt mal Arbeit neu organisieren und vielleicht den ein oder anderen Befreiungsschlag dank KI nutzen.
Die Zukunft gestalten.
Genau, wir können jetzt schon mal überlegen, wer von beiden.
Ich überlege gerade, wer könnte es sein. Ich habe Clips dabei von Adam Tooze. Wir wollen das nämlich auch auf eine ökonomische Grundlage stellen, denn die Frage ist ja, was passiert, wenn es eine Blase ist und was ist, wenn es keine Blase ist. Und beide Antworten sind vielleicht ein bisschen besorgniserregend. Wir sollen ja hier auch, denn das ist ja im Rahmen einer Tagung veranstaltet worden, dieser Live-Podcast am Abend, über Latenz und latente Räume sprechen. Deshalb habe ich auch ein paar Clips von Elena Esposito dabei, die sich ja mit maschinellem Lernen und der maschinellen Sprache auseinandergesetzt hat, da ein paar Punkte, warum das eben doch sehr anders ist bei der KI als bei Menschen. Und obwohl das so ist, können wir trotzdem kommunizieren oder vielleicht brauchen wir auch gar nicht das Verständnis des anderen. Also wir sind da bei dem Begriff der doppelten Kontingenz und sind dann auch vielleicht schon sehr schnell bei der Latente angekommen. Also was für Räume eröffnen sich da, vielleicht Illusionsräume oder sonst etwas, wenn wir etwas eingeben in die KI, die weiß nicht, was wir da eigentlich wollen. Wir wissen nicht genau, gibt es so etwas wie einen Willen bei der KI? Was spuckt sie uns aber dann am Ende aus und was machen wir damit? Beziehungsweise ist ja auch die Frage, wenn derart spekuliert wird darauf, dass die künstliche Intelligenz vielleicht sogar übermächtig wird, was schwingt da eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit, was nicht so klar präsent ist, aber doch anwesend ist in irgendeiner Weise.
Simulation, Spiel und Spekulation.
Ja.
Alle drei großen Themen kommen heute bei uns vor.
Gut. Und wer das hören mag, kommt einfach in den Salon. Das ist möglich über Patreon, Apple und wir empfehlen es besonders Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Dort kommt man dann direkt zu Steady, hat dann nicht nur Zugang, wenn man ein Abo abschließt zu diesem Live-Salon, sondern zu allen Live-Salons und zu allen regulären Salons. Wir sprechen ja im Dezember noch über Branko Milanovic Buch im regulären Salon. Und wir haben ja nochmal einen Live-Salon im Dezember, kurz vor Weihnachten, dann traditionell in der Käs.
Viel Spaß nun und für Salonmitglieder gilt, ihr kriegt es bis zum Schluss.
Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von PROKON. Was ist PROKON? PROKON ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften, da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland. Und PROKON ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es PROKON in Deutschland, Polen, Finnland und Spanien. PROKON setzt auf Wind onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethan. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dieses Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an PROKON, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen, die 40.000 Mitglieder. Egal, wie viel man reinbringt, die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus. Aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken PROKON sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von 3 bis 5 Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu PROKON in unseren Show Notes. Also greift mal in eure Hosentasche.
Guten Abend, Düsseldorf.
Wir sind also zu euch gepaaren. Wir sind die einzigen nicht NRWler hier im Raum, haben wir gerade festgestellt. Und da es heute Abend ein Thema gibt, Latenz, müssen wir es kurz thematisieren. Wir stehen alle noch unter dem Eindruck, dass wir den Techniker gerade ins Schwitzen gebracht haben, weil ein Brummen zu hören war, für das wir verantwortlich sind und nicht die Haustechnik. Das wird aber jetzt, kriegt es einen grünen Haken. Wir haben es jetzt abgeschlossen, wir hoffen es kommt nicht wieder und können jetzt in unser Thema starten.
Das heißt, wir stehen der Technik doch immer wieder gegenüber und wissen eigentlich nicht, was zu tun ist.
Ja, so ist es. Sie ist unberechenbar, wir kriegen sie überhaupt nicht gebändigt.
Nein, das ja nicht, wie wir noch heute Abend erfahren werden. Aber vielleicht geben wir kurz den Kontext für diejenigen, die jetzt hier sind oder uns zuhören. Es ist so, dass hier eine Tagung stattfindet zum Thema Latent Space, Latente Räume. Es gibt eine Filmreihe, die durfte ich kuratieren. Dort gibt es zu sehen zum Thema Latent Arrival, Cachet von Michael Hannecke, hast du vielleicht gesehen, dann von Claude Sauté, Die Dinge des Lebens und das ist schon am Donnerstag gezeigt worden, Marlene, ein Dokumentarfilm von Maximilian Schell über Marlene Dietrich aus dem Jahr 1981. Ich will dir nur ganz kurz davon erzählen, denn es ist ja so, dass Marlene Dietrich sich 1975 zurückgezogen hat aus der Öffentlichkeit und sagt, die Legende muss weiterleben. Das bedeutet aber, mein biologischer Körper muss versteckt werden vor der Öffentlichkeit. Also blieb sie in diesem Pariser Apartment, ließ sich nicht mehr fotografieren oder filmen. Aber Maximilian Schell hat sie überredet zu einem sechs-tägigen Interview und aus diesen Tonbandaufnahmen hat er dann einen Film kollagiert. Das Besondere nun daran ist aber, dass wir permanent Kommunikation scheitern sehen, weil Maximilian Schell gerne mit Marlene Dietrich über ihr Verb sprechen möchte und Interpretationen vorschlägt und all das. Und Marlene Dietrich macht eine Totalverweigerung, sagt eigentlich zu jedem Satz, weil das ist ja Quatsch, also ich bitte Sie und nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nur in dieser Art kommuniziert sie. Also das ist so fehlende Kommunikation. Und es gibt eine sehr schöne Aussage von Maximilian Schell, dann später im Spiegel, dann sagte er, sie wusste nicht, was ich von ihr wollte. Und ich wusste es aber auch nicht so richtig. Und da sind wir doch eigentlich schon mitten an unserem Thema der Latenz. Und wie kommunizieren wir eigentlich mit den intelligenten Maschinen?
Und gab es denn in dem Film einen Mehrwert, den man unscheinbar, unsichtbar, wie auch immer, hätte lassen müssen, wenn sie eine Dampfplauderin gewesen wäre?
Nein, es geht nur so. Also nur deshalb hat der Film den Mehrwert, weil die Kommunikation die ganze Zeit scheitert. Weil wir hier was erfahren, wie Filme gemacht werden. Nämlich, es gibt Intentionen. Aber das müssen nicht die Intentionen sein, die uns zu interessieren haben. Wir sehen auch da was über Textbildschere. Also man kann sich mal das bei YouTube ansehen. Leider gibt es den Film nirgends verfügbar. Aber man kann sich mal bei YouTube ansehen, wie Marlene Dietrich dann schon mit 70 und älter singt den Song Johnny, wenn du Geburtsdag hast. Und dann kann man mal beobachten, wie sie das Mikrofon so betastet. Und die Assoziationen sind sehr naheliegend, was da eigentlich versinnbildlich wird. Und wir hören aber jetzt in dem Interview Marlene Dietrich die ganze Zeit, wir hatten ja von der Erotik keine Ahnung, wussten ja gar nicht, was wir da tun. Also sie versucht die ganze Zeit zu verweigern, dass da irgendeine Intention war. Und wenn sie auch vielleicht nicht da war, auf uns wirkt es natürlich trotzdem, dass uns klar ist, was hier erotisch evoziert werden soll. Und damit können wir wieder einmal sehen, dass wir nicht in die Köpfe derjenigen hineinblicken können, mit denen wir sprechen. Und wir können ja auch nicht genau wissen, was die KI jetzt gerade so macht. Aber sie gibt eine Antwort. Und vielleicht gelingt die Kommunikation besser als bei Max Schelle und Marlene.
Also, latente Räume ist ja ein sehr mutiger Themeinschlag. Aber hier kann man es sehen, denn offenbar ist der latente Raum die Vergangenheit, in der Sachen entschwunden sind und damit fast unwiederbringbar verloren. Aber die gute Erinnerung, wir haben ja ein ausreichend großes Tokenfenster, um sozusagen, wir wissen dann nochmal, was uns der Schäle eigentlich zeigen wollte. Und dann findet Kopfkino statt. Auch ein latenter Raum, Kopfkino, da kommen wir später drauf zu sprechen.
Wir sollten erstmal uns auf eine ökonomische Grundlage begeben, wenn wir über KI sprechen, über den KI-Hype. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, nehmen wir einen alten Bekannten, Adam Tooze, der hat ja auch einen Podcast für das Surplus-Magazin, wird dort auch zu KI befragt und sagt Folgendes.
Das Versprechen, man muss es ja auch so formulieren, das Versprechen der Befürworter von KI ist, dass sie den allergrößten.